today on the Matt Walsh show three brave
high school girls are suing to keep boys
off of girls sports in the states but
the judge has rigged the case against
them in a really outrageous way that you
just have to hear about now we touched
on this story briefly on the show
yesterday but I want to go into more
depth on it because I think it deserves
more attention certainly more attention
than it's going to get in mass media
also 5 headlines including a developing
showdown in Pennsylvania between the
dictator governor and county officials
who want to reopen against his wishes I
think we're gonna see more of this than
states across the country we probably
need to see more of this of elected
officials who are sane and reasonable
and realize on the local level that we
need to get things going again and I
think they're gonna have to just start
doing that despite what the dictator
emperor in the governor's mansion thinks
so we'll talk about that Plus emails
some emails about the Marbury case and
much more as well coming up on the show
but before we get to any of that I want
to tell you about our good friends at
light stream light stream one of our
loyal sponsors I want to thank all of
our sponsors for supporting us during
this time and in you for supporting us
and also just just to ask you that you
know when you're listening to the show
if you hear us talk about a sponsor
selling a product you're interested in
then consider supporting them and going
to them for for what you're looking for
so like stream you know right now saving
every penny you can is especially
important including on your credit card
balance again you guys start looking at
all of the different areas where you
could save money and this is this is an
area that a lot of people I think forget
about you get a rate as low as five
point nine five percent APR with Auto
pay much lower than the national average
credit card rate of over 19% APR plus
there are absolutely no fees the
application is quick and easy it's a
hundred percent online light stream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver people
love like she okay here's what this
customer had to say I heard about light
stream while listening to one of my
favorite podcasts and it prompted me to
do some more research after shopping
around for a personal loan that would
help me get a lower interest rate there
was no one easier to work with plus life
stream had the best rate by far better
yet no fees I had my cash within two
business days overall amazing experience
highly recommend you can apply today to
get a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get this
discount
is to go to light stream calm / wolf
that's lig HT s TR II am calm / Walsh
subjective credit approval rates include
0.5% auto pay discount terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit light
stream calm / Walsh for more information
ok so story reported by The Daily wire
yesterday and that I mentioned as I said
briefly during the headlines segment of
the show this this shows what we're up
against in our culture in in the fight
for truth and sanity because that's
that's what this is really about on the
most basic level we're just fighting for
rationality and sanity and common sense
and I think we have to get there first
before we can before we can get to you
know the deeper things three high school
girls in Connecticut are in a legal
dispute over the state's decision to
allow males who identify as transgender
to compete on girls sports teams now in
Connecticut two boys in particular on
dry a year would and Terry Miller are
the names they go by have been basically
dominating the female circuit for a
couple of years these would be middling
athletes athletes if they were to
compete against their own kind boys
against boys they're you know middle the
pack mediocre runners but against the
girls they just rake in the wins
sometimes you know in some races that
they have taken first and second place
between the two of them now the lawsuit
filed by Selena Sol Alana Smith and
Chelsea Mitchell those are all real
girls by the way seek to put a stop to
this madness in the lawsuit basically
the case the lawsuit is making is that
males have a biological inherent
biological advantage over girls and so
therefore we that's why we've in the
past had this really common sense system
of you know putting the the two sexes in
their own sports leagues let's go back
to that that's the case that these girls
are making but just as the track races
are rigged against them now so it seems
is the courtroom District Judge Robert
pigmy presiding over the case recently
instructed lawyers for the plaintiffs
that they may not refer to trans
athletes as male okay here's the full
quote I read this yesterday on the show
and read it again remember this is a
judge in a courtroom this this is not a
you know like a gender studies professor
at some university this is this is this
is what a judge is saying this is a
transcript from the conference call with
the lawyers and here's what he said what
I'm saying is you must refer to them as
transgender females rather than as males
again that's the more accurate
terminology and I think that it fully
protects your clients legitimate
interests referring to these individuals
as transgender females is consistent
with science common practice and perhaps
human decency to refer to them as males
period is not accurate certainly not as
accurate and I think it's needlessly
provocative I don't think that you
surrender any legitimate interest or
position if you refer to them as
transgender females that is what the
case is about this isn't a case
involving males who decided that they
want to run and girls events this is a
case about girls who say that
transgender girls should not be allowed
to run in girls events so going forward
we will not refer to the proposed
intervenors as males understood and then
they were told that if if they really
have trouble complying with this order
they have to take it to the Court of
Appeals you know if for some reason to
take knees order that they can't call
males male troubles them then they'll
have to take it to a different court and
now the lawyers are calling for to take
me to recuse himself correctly pointing
out that the judge has quote destroyed
the appearance of impartiality in this
proceeding indeed he has done exactly
that the judge has come out not just as
a believer in left-wing gender theory
not not just that I mean that would be
bad enough but he's come out as one of
the more radical proponents of it
actually
because calling Trant quote-unquote
trans girls female that's what he's
saying he's saying there's I'm just
saying they're girls you're saying
they're female and that is a step beyond
what even many defenders of Yearwood and
miller and other
trans athletes would say the usual line
is that there's some kind of vague
distinction between girl and female so
that a girl might be a girl but not
necessarily female that's the usual line
that we hear and that line is incoherent
and crazy enough as it is and it makes
no sense but it's not as crazy or as
incoherent as to flat-out claim that
individuals with XY chromosomes and
penises are female which is what he's
saying and that the craziest and most
incoherent version of the pro trans
argument is the one that this judge not
only believes but is trying to impose on
the girls as a prerequisite for their
lawsuit to continue now the problem of
course is that the fact that the trans a
flutes are male is the whole point the
in the girls entire case is that males
and females are biologically different
and those differences grant males
inherent advantages in most athletic
competitions if they can't make that
case then they can't make any case
because that's the only case and it's a
pretty good case I would say if they
have to pretend for the sake of the
lawsuit that boys are female then they
lose the very basis for the lawsuit this
is the point that judge cheetah Guinea
pretends not to understand remember this
part of his little lecture there he says
this isn't a case involving males who
have decided that they want to run in
girls events on the contrary your honor
that is exactly what the case involves
that is exactly what the case is males
who want to run in girl's events that's
what it is by definition if they were
females competing against other females
there would be no reason for a lawsuit
we wouldn't be a problem I'm thinking
that these girls who filed the lawsuit
have raced against many other girls
hundreds of other girls never an issue
now it is why is that because they're
not girls and they're certainly not
female now I only wish that the lawyers
for the girls had thought to ask the
judge
simple question which which i think is
very relevant question and to say well
well okay judge you say they're female
what's that
can you define the word female I mean he
apparently thinks that a female is
somebody with X with XX chromosomes or
somebody with XY chromosomes and that
pretty much covers the whole gamut of
human possibilities so then that would
mean that the judge thinks that a female
is really nothing in particular if he
has a definition for the word that would
allow it to retain some kind of distinct
and objective and unique meaning while
also permitting penis wielding ex wives
to fall under its umbrella I'd really
like to hear what that definition is but
I don't think he can provide one I don't
think anyone can provide one because
I've been asking as you know for like a
year and I have yet to get a response
and whatever definition of the word
female or woman that judge to take me
might offer now you know I have to
wonder if it would be the same
definition that he would have offered
five or ten years ago the judge at 68
years old I'm guessing that if I were to
go back to when he would say 60 years
old and ask him if if if men can have
babies or if women can have penises he
would offer a firm no on both counts it
could be wrong you know it's it's
possible that he's been a radical
babbling incoherently about transgender
females for most of his adult life
that's possible I tend to doubt it
because 10 years ago no one but the most
fringe militant on the LGBTQ left was
entertaining any of this nonsense you
didn't hear about it
and that's not to say that people who
identify as transgender didn't exist ten
years ago they did obviously but it
wasn't an issue we weren't talking about
it and there was almost nobody going
around saying that men can have babies
women can penises there was almost
nobody arguing that men should be in the
women's bathroom or that we should have
boys racing against girls
you know I ran track when I was in high
school and and this this never came up
it was just never an issue nobody ever
talked about it now if you want proof
that nobody was talking about this ten
years ago all you have to do is look at
what every Democrat on the national
stage was saying about the issue of
transgenderism during the Bush years or
any time before that just go back and
google it think of any of these elected
Democrats who've been on the scene for a
while google their name with transgender
and you know do it do a search by
timeframe go back to you know I don't
know 2007 what were they saying about it
it wouldn't take long to check because
they weren't saying much of anything
about it now all of them though now all
of them from Chuck Schumer to Joe Biden
claims to believe that men are women and
women are men did they believe that this
whole time but they just never said
anything until the last few years have
they have they held this belief within
themselves for four decades or did they
decide suddenly collectively almost
overnight that the country is filled
with females trapped in male bodies and
the only appropriate response to this
epidemic is to invite boys in the girls
locker rooms and onto girls sports teams
now the latter would seem to be the case
here that this was a in almost overnight
transition as a war which raises the
question what prompted this drastic
change of mind what sparked judge
chittock knees epiphany assuming that if
I had asked chick a cheetah Guinea at 60
you know is is there such a thing as a
female with with XY chromosomes and a
penis assuming that if I'd ask Tom Lee
60 years old you would he would have
said no now he's saying that there is
what happened in between why did he
change his mind what about Joe Biden Joe
Biden is is is 78 years old that means
up and
the age of like 70 at least he thought
he was living in a world where men are
men women are women and that's pretty
much it he changed his mind why cheat
igni says that the science tells us
about transgender females what science
tell me about the site don't just say
signs either the science says it science
says it that's the thing I think that
sometimes left us don't understand
you can't just shout the word science
and have that count as making a
scientific argument you can't go around
shouting you mean you make a claim and
someone says where are you getting that
from you can't say I got it from science
science told me like science is some
sort of like creature that that
invisible creature that whispers in your
ear and tells you things science is a is
a method for ascertaining and
understanding the truth of the physical
world so tell me about that method don't
just say science what what by what
method did you did you discover that men
can have babies I mean can you name a
scientific breakthrough a discovery that
validates this claim you're making
here's the thing it takes your technique
for example at some point he decided
that girls have penises I mean not to be
too crude about it but that's but that's
what he decided I think it's fair to ask
why he decided that and win and is he
really quite sure that he wasn't right
about this issue the first time and if
we had a real news media this same
question will be asked of every single
elected Democrat I would love to see
this question asked just once of one of
these people they are all making
breathtaking claims about human
sexuality and the nature of human beings
and those claims wildly contradict what
most of them have said on the subject
for their entire lives until just five
seconds ago okay it is this not a
flip-flop is this not arguably the weird
and most dramatic flip-flop in political
history can you think of a more dramatic
one can you think of one stranger than
this where you had politicians that went
from you know women have vaginas men
have penises - you can Mitch and Matt
mix and match them I think that deserves
further investigation I think we should
be asking why did you change your mind
on this what happened
simple question see on this issue I
asked really simple fair questions it's
not a gotcha well I asked the question
of can you define the one word woman or
when did you decide that men can have
babies and what made you decide that
simple question is there's there's no
solid gotcha
there's no ulterior motive I really want
to know however you explained the shift
we are now left with a country where
millions of people believe or pretend to
believe any way that a biological male
can wake up in the morning announced
that he's a female and the only morally
acceptable response from society is
enthusiastic affirmation and to just
give him whatever he wants including
access to the girls locker room and the
girls sports teams and this ideology has
seeped in to rapidly seeped into every
institution especially our academic
institutions but now we find out even in
the courtrooms and so that is the fight
that we are dealing with let's go on to
headlines as referenced earlier a
looming showdown is developing in
Pennsylvania some counties in the state
are planning to reopen regardless of
what the governor Tom Wolfe has to say
and they've decided to take it upon
themselves to make these decisions not
waiting for the emperor to give his
approval and good for them I mean this
is exactly what needs to happen
officials you know those who are in
power who are sane and reasonable and
understand that we need to save our
economy before it's too late they need
to step up and just do the right thing
regardless of what any dictator and any
governor's mansion says and so that's
happening in some counties pencil
but Tom wolf is not gonna take this
defiance lightly so he issued a string
of tweets yesterday and let me read some
of what he has to say I mean this is
this is just a temper tantrum from a man
who does not want to be defied he says I
won't sit back and watch residents who
live in counties under state homeowners
get sick because local leaders cannot
see the risks of Cova 19 and push to
reopen prematurely today I'm announcing
consequences for counties that do not
abide by the law to remain closed
non-compliant counties won't be eligible
for federal federal stimulus
discretionary funds discretionary funds
instead those funds will be allocated to
counties working to stop the spread of
cover 19 businesses should know that
opening in counties that don't abide by
the law will potentially jeopardize
their business liability insurance or
the protections it provides dining in
restaurants that opening counties that
have not been authorized to reopen will
risk receiving a citation these
citations can also me lead to the loss
of restaurants liquor license if your
county reopens prematurely and you don't
feel comfortable returning to work rest
assured that the Commonwealth will allow
you to continue to receive unemployment
compensation even if your employer
reopens we are fighting a war that has
taken lives of too many people and we're
winning the politicians who are
encouraging us to quit the fight are
acting in a most cowardly way cowards
this is what he decrees from his throne
he calls them cowards yes if you don't
listen to obey comply with his orders
you're a coward
that's the way it works now an
upside-down land now a lot could be said
in response to this from Tom Wolfe but
I'll just mention one thing a reminder
as I've discussed on the show throughout
the last week or two because I I do
think this is this is this is the big
story of the corona virus epidemic in
America Tom Wolfe is one of the
governors who sent by mandate sent
infected people into nursing homes he is
directly responsible for many deaths he
is a grandma killer calling people
grandma killers left and right well he's
the grandma killer along with Cuomo
along with the governor of
you know along with a Newsome in
California and other governors who made
the same decision New Jersey he has no
credibility
he has no moral authority this epidemic
would would have been the death toll
would be a fraction a fraction of what
it currently is if guys like Tom Wolfe
and Cuomo and others had actually
protected nursing homes rather than
directly putting them in harm's way
number two speaking of not being a
coward The Daily wire reports Tesla CEO
Elon Musk has reopened the company's
manufacturing plant and almita
County California elevating his public
feud with interim public health officer
dr. Erica pan who has prohibited the
company from resuming businesses via a
countywide order that is more strict
than the governor's Public Health order
in a tweet on Monday afternoon musk said
that Tesla would begin to ramp up
production in the county which includes
the Fremont facility where over 10,000
people have jobs musk said Tesla is
restarting production today against
Alameda County rules I will be on the
line with everybody else if anyone is
arrested I ask that it only be me so I
think that's again this is this is what
we're gonna see people are whether it's
individual businesses we've already seen
that with the salon owner down in Texas
and other places or County officials you
know people are just gonna start to do
the right thing regardless of what any
mandate or directive or order from the
governor says and so if you don't want
total lawlessness if you don't want this
thing to get out of control then you
need to step back and let people get
back to their lives because that's gonna
happen regardless I think we've reached
a point where people are getting back to
their lives no matter what you say you
could fight against it do you start
issuing citations putting people in jail
have more chaos or you can start
facilitating this transition back into
freedom and sanity let's see what else
according to the AP it says Twitter
announced Monday it will start alerting
users when a tweet makes disputed or
misleading claims about the corner virus
the new rule is the latest in a wave of
stricter policies that tech companies
are rolling out to confront an outbreak
of virus related misinformation on their
sites Facebook and Google have already
put similar systems in place now this of
course is what the the left has been
pushing for they know that Silicon
Valley is on their side idea Lodge I do
logically so they want these tech giants
to censor to decide what information is
true or worthy of reaching our ears and
our eyeballs and that's fine you know if
if it's not I'm not in favor of it but
if that's the position they want to take
they're free to take it if they want to
celebrate censorship and celebrate the
control of information by massive
corporations they're entitled to that
view but then my only request is don't
turn around and talk about how evil
corporations are and how we need to
break their influence over our culture
and our country and our politics don't
do that don't do that after applauding
billion-dollar corporations as they put
themselves in the position of being
arbiters of truth because if you're
going to push for them to do that and
celebrate it then you are putting a lot
of trust in their hands number four a
headline in the mirrors and this is a
headline that you you almost won't
believe it's real but it is headline
says deadly coronavirus has proven that
women are strong the stronger sex court
of ours proves that women are the
stronger sex the article written by Jane
Simmons claims that because more men are
dying of the coronavirus women are
stronger so girl power
right she is act this this writer of an
article that was was published in a
publication is actually gloating
she wrote a whole article gloating about
men dying from the disease so we need
not imagine how it would be received if
somebody wrote an article claiming that
women dying of breast cancer proves that
they're the weaker sex
to imagine it because we know that would
be received exactly as it should be
received with contempt and scorn and
mockery which is how this should be
received too but aside from you know the
loathsomeness of gloating over deaths
and aside from from the absurdity of
claiming that that one sex is weaker
because it's more susceptible to a
particular illness especially when both
sexes have different illnesses that
they're more susceptible to it has
nothing to do with strength or weakness
aside from all that here again we have a
feminist forgetting that she's not
allowed to make these kinds of points
anymore
because this acknowledges biological
differences between men and women in
fact she even says that verbatim in the
article that there are biological
differences physical difference in men
and women if you're a left-wing feminist
you're not allowed to say that anymore
that's that's out the window because if
you say that it completely destroys the
case for transgenderism so you have to
choose you can't have both either men
and women are interchangeable and the
physical differences are non-existence
or non-existent or inconsequential or
men and women are different physically
immutably biologically one or the other
can't be both and yes if if you're
noticing if you're a feminist and you're
noticing that by accepting the the the
the trans narrative you are forfeiting
all the girl power stuff all the women's
rights stuff you know all the women are
better than men's stuff all the
demonization of men I mean you all that
goes out the window because there's no
difference anymore between these two
groups the only difference is is social
it's a social construct arbitrary
subjective so yeah if you're left-wing
feminist maybe you're noticing that but
then either you can just shut up and
comply with did with the trans narrative
and and the the LGBT narrative or you
can fight back against it to try to
reclaim your your own narrative but
the two can't coincide they can't work
together
number five finally big news here the
artist Takashi six nine one of my
personal favorites just got out of
prison couple days ago after he snitched
on his friends for to get a lighter
sentence so he was you know arrested
originally for I don't know what was it
I don't know murder or something drugs I
wanted something like that but he any
turned snitch he snitched on his friends
in his in his gang and so he got a
lighter sentence and he just got
released from prison was supposed to be
like 40 or 50 years but because he
snitched you got a light sentence and
then with the corner virus thing and he
has asthma so they let it look they let
him out even earlier and so now he's out
but the thing is he's a rapper and you
know being a snitch as a rapper kind of
frowned upon so he went to Instagram
live and he tried to explain himself and
tried to do a little bit of damage
control and here's how that went it
wasn't worth it it wasn't and I'm gonna
tell you what if there is a street code
right if there is a street code and
there's something so so called is
loyalty and everything and no snitching
and all that I get it right but where
was the loyalty when you were sleeping
with my baby mother where was the law
you see when you was caught on the white
side trying to tell me what was the
lawyer to when he tried to kidnap my
mother
where was the lawyer T when you still
means that where was that so who broke
it first I I get it don't fight fire
fire I'm sorry but what did I do wrong
be loyal to that's my baby moms be loyal
to that kidnapped me beat the [ __ ] outta
me on video on everything I'm supposed
to be loyal to that nerd you know what
your what it is y'all want to accept the
fact that those are all true facts yeah
I don't want to exit not understand why
snitch I understand yeah I don't want to
understand it's not that I don't
understand you I don't want to
understand you I don't want to
understand that damn this kid really was
he moved their families out of poverty
he he paid for school for all of the
members whatever but he snitched on them
why were they law you to me cuz I when I
met when I met
son he was sleeping on the road I'll
give him money look listen I'm a rainbow
Mexican here kid I rap
turn around I'm not about that gang but
listen I know how to get us out
you wasn't worried to me weather weather
which I understand less ya understand
and I know you understand you I don't
wanna understand I do
I do understand Takashi six nine I do
I've been there myself all that I can
relate to everything that was just said
honestly even the tattoos the hair
that's how I look on the weekends it's
pretty uncanny I just covered up with
makeup during the week but the whole
look is great I mean he looks like a
Batman villain whose origin story is
that he fell into a giant pie dyeing
machine and that's what I that's what I
love about about it
or he looks like I don't know like a My
Little Pony character that you know
after the show ended got addicted to
methamphetamines or something but anyway
you know you know what he's when he's
saying what he's saying about about
whatever he's saying is deeply deeply
significant and as I said relatable to
me and indeed to all humanity I mean
listen to his words listen know what he
said there at the end he said you
understand and I know you understand you
don't want to understand you understand
I know you understand you don't want to
understand well think about that think
what what he's saying so much truth
there he's basically saying listen truth
itself okay the most difficult truths of
life are self-evident to us we have an
innate understanding of the truth but
how often alas have we wished to not
understand how often have we wished that
we did not know what we do indeed know
how often have we looked upon the
innocence of a child and said if only if
only I could have that instance back
that ignorance that blissful ignorance
and that's that's what I take from
Takashi o-69
and that's why he's one of the great
artists and one of the great poets I
wanted great thinkers of our time and
I'm just glad he's out of prison finally
so I can once again enjoy his
philosophical musings and his angelic
music angelic music that is for years to
come
or until he gets shot for being a snitch
I mean whichever comes first but well
we'll pray for him okay let's go on to
our daily cancellation and it's a quick
one today today we're canceling whoever
wrote this letter to slate the letter is
I love my boyfriend but want a
girlfriend that's how the letter and the
advice column is is titled on Slate but
that's not really the cancellable part
okay I mean it is cancelable but don't
get me wrong but you need you need to do
more than that these days okay just just
wanting a polyamorous relationship that
could have got you canceled by me a few
years ago but you got a you got to
impress me just normal degeneracy isn't
gonna do it okay
so let's read the actual letter this is
what it says in part my partner is the
most compassionate loving and respectful
partner I could ask for it
he supported me through difficult times
weight fluctuations questioning my
gender changing my name sobriety among
other things I am incredibly attracted
to women
he knows this and we have talked about
opening our relationship however he is
on the spectrum of asexuality and is
only interested in having sex with me
did you catch it he's on the spectrum of
asexuality why because he wants to be
monogamous that now puts you on the
spectrum of asexuality we'll get back to
that in a minute but I also wanted to
take note of this part here okay the
thought of me having sex with other
people makes them deeply uncomfortable
as we both relate to sex in very
different ways we have had this
conversation a few times in the year but
that we've been together but with no
solid plan or outcome yet we've had this
conversation a few times in the year
that we've been together with no solid
planner I cam okay so this guy has been
with this girl for a year I'm assuming
it's a girl and a guy but who really
knows at this point but I'll just let's
just go with that for the second bug
this guy has been with this girl for a
year and he's alright
put up with everything she listed to the
top difficult times weight fluctuation
questioning my name questioning my
gender changing my name
sobriety among other things one can only
imagine what the other things might be
in a list like that and now she goes off
and she wants to sleep with other people
all of that in a year and and they
aren't married or anything so the real
advice that needs to be given here is to
the is to the the guy to the other
person
and that needs to be like get the hell
out just run away as fast as you can
what are you doing you fool what are you
thinking subjecting yourself to listen
you you usually see the sameness of a
person in the first year ask my wife
okay
first year of being with my wife is the
same as that been around her okay
it just it's mentally it all goes
downhill from there right like because
that's that's when people are putting on
their sameness front but especially for
me you can only pretend to be sane for
so long before your internal craziness
comes out so you keep that in mind so if
you're the guy what you have to realize
is that change the name change the
gender everything
fluctuating weight sobriety this and
that that's that's the same as she's
gonna get and it's all it's only getting
crazier from there so and of course this
advice really applies to anyone if your
boyfriend or girlfriend tells you that
let me forget about everything else but
if your boyfriend/girlfriend tells you
that they want to see other people and
have an open relationship that is
definitely a don't pass go don't collect
$200 just get the hell out kind of
moment no need for a discussion that's
the good thing about it so it should be
a very easy and clean break if your
girlfriend sits you down and says you
know I was thinking I'd like to have an
open relationship the great thing is
that you don't need to say anything your
response is say nothing just okay stand
up walk out walk out the door never talk
to him again there's no reason to even
talk anymore it's it's done at that
point but back to the
a spectrum of asexuality thing because
this is really interesting and it's
relevant to me personally because I
never realized that I was asexual you
know most of you probably aren't
surprised to find out that I am but I'm
a little bit surprised to me I always
thought that I was in a monogamous
relationship with my wife
turns out I'm on the spectrum of
asexuality I'm just a hop skip and a
jump away from being a full-on asexual
amoeba reproducing through
self-replication that's I'm very close
to that so you notice what's happening
in our culture slowly but surely and
this is always a trajectory because
first we're told ok it's ok to be
different to be weird to have different
kinds of desires something that's the
people think is perverse it's not you
know it's or even if it is it's ok you
want to be polyamorous that's fine yeah
it's different but it's fine that's the
first step and then we're told actually
know these kinds of desires they aren't
they aren't really even different
they're really normal as lots of people
feel this way even if they don't say it
it's all normal everything is normal you
know there is no abnormal or normal
everything's normal and so and so it's
fine
that's the second step the third step is
to say actually these things that you
thought were abnormal are not only
normal but the opposite of these things
the previously normal things they're the
abnormal things and I know we've told
you that it's okay to be abnormal we
changed our minds those abnormal things
are bad you should hate those so that's
where this heads heads to a place where
being in a monogamous heterosexual
relationship is spurned is treated as
freakish as radical as on some sort of
weird spectrum there's something wrong
with you that you're you're you know in
a relationship with someone and you only
desire them well what's wrong with you
you freak that's where all this heads
okay finally let's go to emails as
always a lot of infamy leather about the
mod Arbor II case so here's one from
John says Matt I think you're wrong in
the case of a Matar berry I think you're
can
conclusion so far as flawed simply
because you're ignoring the additional
information that has come to light since
the original video was leaked there are
now no less than two additional sources
of video and no less than four
additional witnesses in addition to that
our burry has been linked by the police
to four other cases of theft and
burglary in the area where the shooting
took place the new video clearly shows
our burry walking not running or jogging
up the street as he approaches a
construction site he then looks both
ways to see if anyone is watching him
before running up the driveway and
entering the connection site via the
garage video from inside the
construction site shows him looking
around the external video then shows
someone from across the street walking
towards the house shouting at our Barry
at this point are we free flees down the
road this is when McMichael the
McMichaels video takes over given this
information I can reasonably come to a
conclusion that McMichaels were indeed
attempting a citizen's arrest
first and foremost Arby's behavior
approaching the house is inconsistent
with the idea that he was out for a jog
secondly under Georgia law by entering
the house with the intent of stealing
something our burry was already guilty
of a felony the fact that our burries
offense was a felony allows McMichaels
to pursue an attempt a citizen's arrest
under georgia law georgia is also an
open carry state and once our be charged
him both McMichaels and our burry had a
legal standing for self defense claim no
matter what the outcome of the
confrontation taking all that into
consideration looking at both parties
involved one party is consistently law
abiding while the other was breaking the
law at least twice prior to the
confrontation this leads me to believe
that our burry was fleeing potential
felony charges not a racist beatdown
this also leads me to give McMichaels
the benefit of the doubt as he is
innocent until proven guilty okay well
John I think some of your information is
just so I think some of your information
is incorrect and I also think that
you're making a lot of assumptions and
but not framing them as assumptions
you're framing them as facts so you say
that our burry has been linked to four
other cases of burglary and theft where
did you find that I I haven't seen that
anywhere and I've looked so I don't I
don't that that I don't I don't think
that's true you you talked about the
video of our burry and I mean you have
this whole description of the video
outside the construction site looking
around to see if anyone's watching see
you're you're making assumptions about
his intention
and you're also doing this based on I've
looked at that video I mean I've seen
this the video you're talking about
there are two other videos as you
mentioned there's a video from outside
the construction site you're talking
about there's also video of barberry
inside the construction site but the
video outside it's it's really hard to
see anything I don't know how I mean you
you have you you've come up with with a
lot of very specific details I would
tell anyone watching this right now go
look at the video that he's talking
about it's really hard to tell what the
hell's going on it's it's it's it's
distant and great and grainy and it's
hard to tell and in the video inside the
construction site all we see is the guy
walking in and looking around that's all
we see if anything more sinister
happened it's not on the video you say
that our burry went in with the intent
to steal well how do you know that I
mean that's yes if he went in with the
intent to steal that's very convenient
for your case because then you could say
it was you know at least the the
intention of a felony and if you go into
a place look in this deal and you don't
steal because there's nothing to steal
is it still a felony I mean maybe it is
I'm not exactly sure how the law works
there but but that's a hell of an
assumption that you're making and I
don't know how you could possibly make
it you could say well I can't imagine
why else you'd be in a construction site
okay I fine that might be why he's there
but that's that's you see understand
that's just your assumption there are
other conceivable reasons why a person
might be in a construction site but
regardless I mean he's dead now so we
can't ask him all we have are the bare
facts as far as we know as far as we
know as far as what we can prove my
manager put it this way as far as what
we can prove is that our burry went into
a construction site briefly looked
around and left that's what we have
anything else that you're gonna assume
about his his motivations is just that
an assumption and the problem is if
you're gonna do that then you can't
complain when people do it with
McMichaels if you're gonna create this
whole narrative of assumptions and
motivations and intent on our brief case
and for our burry then what about what
people do the same with the McMichaels
and say oh they were racist looking for
a black person shoot I don't believe
that they wore that's not
I've said the whole time I mean I I
think that they're wrong and what they
did I think it was more they were just
trying to be the heroes they were trying
to be vigilantes and they were they were
thinking they were like in an action
movie or something that that's that's
what I take from that so I'm not I'm not
in you know assuming racist motivations
but I'm also not assuming motivation as
an arborist part either I'm just trying
to look at what actually happened and
what we can prove now also the the
property owner Larry English says that
nothing was ever stolen from the
property and he never filed any police
report for any reason that's what he
says now I've seen a lot of people
defenders of the McMichaels on twitter
and on social media making all kinds of
claims about how things were stolen and
there was copper wires stolen and this
and that there were all there was all
these break-ins ok well the guy who owns
the property he said that nothing was
ever stolen so that seems rather
significant doesn't it I don't know how
can we just ignore that was anything
stolen let's ask the guy who owns the
property said no we never filed a police
report there was no break-ins
there was no theft or robbery from the
place that's what he said his words if
the guy is saying nothing was stolen
it's reasonable to conclude that our
Reid didn't steal anything and as this
was a construction site not an occupied
residence what you have then at most it
seems like is trespassing which I don't
think is a felony now you claim again
you had the intent to steal but again
how do you know that you can assume it
you can guess it you can theorize about
it you cannot state it as a fact and
here's what I know for sure a civilian
is not entitled to chase somebody down
with guns because of what that civilian
thinks another person might have
intended to do but didn't do and that's
really what this comes down to John
everything else aside for a moment okay
because I don't know if our burry was a
burglar or not maybe he was I mean I'd
be perfectly willing to believe that he
was I don't know anything about him he
could be a burglar sure I don't know I
mean the the way some people that the
whole idea he was Joe
I also don't find that outlandish and uh
there are some people acting like that's
a totally outlandish claim uh he was
jogging maybe he wasn't but what's why
is that weird it's the middle of the day
a guy's out in the street jogging I
don't see anything inherently absurd
about that claim just like it's not
absurd that he was burglar a burglar
either I mean a person could be either
one of those things I think in both
cases there's some weirdness that needs
to be explained like yeah you could say
well if he was jogging then why'd he
stop and instructor say why wasn't he
wearing jogging clothes I mean it's hard
to tell what he's wearing honestly
bouquet those are questions but then
also questions if he was a burglar
why didn't he steal anything what was he
doing out on foot miles from the house
in the middle of the day as a burglar
just that doesn't necessarily seem like
what a burglar would do usually so I
don't know there are questions are the
way but who knows so put it putting all
that aside for a minute because because
we don't know what his intention was
what we do know is that the video
doesn't show our briefs Teeling anything
we know that there was only one reported
burglary in the area seven weeks earlier
we know that that the property owner
says no nothing was stolen all of that
it seems it would seem cuts against the
idea that RB was a burglar but again
putting that aside you as a civilian do
not have the authority to chase somebody
down and confront them in a street while
brandishing a weapon to question them
about a crime you think they committed
and yes holding a weapon and telling
them to stop and come talk to you and
answer a question is brandishing
according to the law you say it was
self-defense that they shot him I don't
think so
it can't be self-defense if you initiate
the altercation brandishing a weapon at
someone in the middle of the street not
in self-defense initially but because
you think they look suspicious and you
want to talk to them that is you
initiating an altercation because the
other guy has every right in every
reason to assume you mean him harm
whether he's a burglar or not so are
buri defended himself so it would be
like if you punched it'd be like if I
punched you and you
punch me then I punch you back and on my
second punch you die I can't claim
self-defense I can't say that Y was diff
I was responding to your punch I was but
I initiated the first punch the whole
punching altercation was initiated by me
and so I don't get to hide by in
self-defense
I'm the aggressor in this case pulling a
gun on someone is the first punch you
are the aggressor yes it's an open carry
state that doesn't mean that you can
just grab your gun and hold it in your
hand and go and go around demanding that
people come talk to you you know not to
mention that stopping your truck in the
middle street you got one guy up with a
gun in his hand in the truck bed you got
another guy gun in his hand on the
street trying to trying to head our
burry off at the pass as a clear case of
brandishing yes open carry does not mean
you can brandish weapons at people and I
think that's a really important point we
should be making as gun rights
supporters we should be saying this is
not what we as gun rights supporters
that is this is not what we're talking
about okay we don't believe that that
that people who have guns you know that
should give them the power and the right
to walk around holding the guns and and
demanding people come talk to them and
you know stopping people in the middle
of the street parking our car in the
middle of the street and pulling our
guns out to go talk to a person with gun
rights supporters we need to be saying
no no that's that's that's not what
we're talking about that that's not what
gun owners do that's not what
responsible gun owners do so to me this
is simple John best case for the
McMichaels is that our burry was a
trespasser and maybe that there's no
evidence of it right now
maybe guilty of stealing a tool or some
nails or I don't know what he'd be
stealing no evidence of that but but
let's just say best case for them that
he did do that
none of that comes close to justifying
three guys grabbing guns and chasing him
down the street you know if he had
killed so if something really sinister
happened in that construction site like
he had killed someone or you know the
attacker assaulted someone and he was
running away that would totally change
the complexion of this case but there's
no evidence of that no one suggested it
I mean so we can assume that's not the
case and what you're left with is
is is you know you're left with you're
left with at best three armed men
chasing a guy down the street because he
was on a construction site you know I'm
sorry I just that that is a massive
overreaction and I doubt that you John
would ever respond that way I mean if
you if you saw someone poking around a
construction site would you would you
call your son would you grab your
shotgun tell your son to come with you
hey get the gun and go chase the guy
down would you because he was in a
construction site for a few minutes I
don't think you would all right let's
but we'll leave it there
I'm open to more information you know if
if more information comes out that
completely changes my perspective on
this then I'll I'll say so I'm not not
I'm not against change in my mind but I
haven't seen anything yet that would
make me do that
well cut it off there thanks I'm ready
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]